I thought it was particularly hurtful
that the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame did
not have the two gentlemen sitting here
next to you uh when you guys were
inducted when they when they didn't have
you to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
that ought to hurt because you have been
in the band 20 years it's sort of absurd
that logic yeah but we were there uh
supporting the whole you know kiss
as an entity we you know we were there
very proud and it would have been nice
to be inducted too but it just didn't
work that way that time and uh you know
just roll with it and the hypocrisy is
that we're not a band they like they
purposely kept us out for 15 years and
other bands that they Embrace they they
induct people's moms and songwriters and
all these people and with us it truly
was unfair why didn't you play at the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame why not go up
and do a performance what was your
thinking there because we had too much
pride in this lineup which is Kiss and
has been kissed for 20 years it's not
newcomers it's this is the band we'll
we'll be back in the stadiums of South
America next month we were there five
months ago we were in Japan this is the
band that has carried the flag and taken
it really to another level this is the
band I always dreamed it would be and
for for us to go on stage they were
demanding quite honestly that we play
with the two original guys Peter and Ace
and at this point that would be
demeaning to the band and also would
give some people confusion because if
you saw people on stage who looked like
kiss but sounded like that maybe we
should be called Piss
right
if there's noting we we've been all over
the world
through decades with this present lineup
it Bears noting I've never seen a single
banner or sign that mentions any other
lineup
right when Tommy takes a solo Tommy
Tommy that's me backstage going Tommy
when Eric takes a solo Eric they're
pumping their fists it's legitimate
nobody is nobody isn't is in kiss and
doing it by the numbers
foreign